We've shown how an image texture can be applied to a model. However, these
sorts of mappings are only skin deep. If we carve away any part of the object,
the fact that a 2D texture is getting used is revealed. What we'd like is
something that's more like a real material. The solution is to create a 3D
texture that fills space. One way to define this texture is to actually create
something like a stack of images. Unfortunately 3D textures are not yet
available in WebGL. My guess is wait a year. Another method is to make a
function that takes in a point on a surface and gives back a color. If you
think about it, these are equivalent in intent. Using images also takes in a 3D
point and gives back a color. Each approach has its strengths and weaknesses.
Functions have an unlimited resolution compared to textures, but you also have
to be careful to filter their results. While I'm at it, I should mention you
can shade points on surfaces however you want with a fragment shader program.
Here's an example of animated procedural textures in use. These examples are 2D
functions. They don't fill space, but show how elaborate effects can be
computed on the fly in the fragment shader.